peu
[Musique]
monique
georges pompidou né le 5 juillet 1911 à
montboudif dans le cantal de parents
instituteurs élu président de la
république le 15 juin 1969
il succède au général de gaulle destin
exceptionnel que celui de georges
pompidou destin tragique aussi de cet
homme qui au sommet de sa carrière
politique sera blessé à mort par une
terrible maladie dont il ne laissera
rien paraître jusqu'aux derniers
instants d'une vie exemplaire qui
s'achève brutalement le 2 avril 1974
un an déjà l'histoire continue
imperturbable et pour les français
l'image du président reste intacte on a
tendance à penser très souvent quand on
voit la carrière de georges pompidou
quand on voit surtout le profil de
l'homme
il a été l'un des derniers présidents
disons humaniste j'aurais tendance en
tout cas penser qu'il est même dans le
monde entier un des derniers hommes
d'état un des derniers hommes de
gouvernement qui ne soit pas passée par
les classes de la science politique ou
la science économique
c'est particulièrement important ce qui
le concerne de noter qu'il est venu au
pouvoir à la politique aux affaires
comme on disait du temps du général de
gaulle par l'école du latin de la poésie
des belles lettres
les humanités des humanités à l'âge de
20 ans georges pompidou après de
brillantes études rentrer à l'école
normale supérieure est reçu premier à
l'agrégation de lettres et diplômé de
l'école libre de sciences politiques
1939 la guerre il sert comme lieutenant
au 141e et ria sur la ligne maginot il
est décoré de la croix de guerre au
cours des combats de la somme il
poursuit sa carrière dans l'enseignement
après marseille c'est au lycée henri iv
à paris
présenté au général de gaulle en 44
justement maître des requêtes au conseil
d'état
il opte en 1954 pour le secteur privé
il revient aux côtés du général dès 1958
il est nommé premier ministre le 14
avril 70 confirmé dans ses fonctions en
66 après l'élection du général de gaulle
au suffrage universel
il est élu député du cantal
circonscription de saint flour en mars
le président le confirme comme premier
ministre en avril 67 après les élections
mai 68 après les difficultés le drame et
la signature des accords de grenelle
ils gagnent les élections et des
missions de vaud l'acceptent mais le
tient en réserve de la république après
le rejet du référendum le 27 avril 69
il annonce sa candidature officielle à
la présidence de la république face à
alain poher il était lui au deuxième
pour le 15 juin et s'installe à l'elysée
le 20 juin 1968
au nom du conseil constitutionnel j'ai
eu l'honneur de proclamer blanc de
pompidou président de la république en
faire
désigné par le peuple français pour
exercer la charge de président de la
république
j'en prends officiellement possession
je voudrais d'abord la personne du
général de gaulle tout au long de ces
dix années
le général de gaulle a ici représenté la
france avec un éclat et une autorité
sans paix c'est mon devoir
mais tracée par son exemple
comme il mais dictée
par la confiance que m'a manifestée le
pays
j'ai la ferme intention de le remplir
dans le strict respect la constitution
de la vème république et avec la volonté
de maintenir la dignité de la france
m
[Musique]
descamps les vis-à-vis de l'extérieur et
notamment en matière de politique
étrangère par commscope vis-à-vis des
autres pays ou leurs représentants
on est la france et ça dit est votre
attitude et vos paroles et vos gestes et
même cela conditionne votre pensée
excellence monsieur à la madeleine
peyroux
c'est l'ambassadeur c'est bien
volontiers que je reçois aujourd'hui les
lettres par lesquels le général juan
velasco alvarado à crédit auprès de nous
comme ambassadeur extraordinaire et
plénipotentiaire du perron président de
la république on est un homme comme les
autres forcément on a donc les mêmes
préoccupations et les mêmes petits
ennuis août les mêmes petites joies que
tout le monde et en même temps on est
toujours chef de l'état alors vous me
montrez en habit dans dés réception
solennelle ou dans des circonstances
officielles
mais si à ce moment là j'ai un soucis de
famille où elle simplement si j'ai un
soulier qui me fait mal vous savez cela
me rappelle très bien que je suis un
homme et inversement inversement quand
je suis à la campagne et même si j'ai
l'air de prendre le soleil dans une
chaise longue et si je le prends
d'ailleurs et avec grand plaisir
eh bien je ne peux pas ne pas me
rappeler que je suis chef de l'état et
qu'à ce titre j'ai des responsabilités
que je ne peux déléguer à personne et
qui pèse sur bois en permanence
le second président de la vème
république assume un héritage difficile
il pratique l'ouverture politique à
l'intérieur en faisant rentrer les
centristes au gouvernement et à
l'extérieur en relançant l'europe qui
prépare le sommet européen de l'année
dès les premiers jours de décembre 60 il
présente devant les chefs d'état
européens un plan d' union économique et
monétaire et se déclare favorable à
l'élargissement de la communauté premier
pas vers l'europe dès septembre 73 il
accomplit un vieux rêve du général de
gaulle il se rend à pékin où il
s'entretient avec mao tsé toung échoué
en laye
il confirme ainsi la reconnaissance
officielle de la chine de mao et
développe les relations culturelles et
économiques entre les deux pays
entre temps il aura visité l'afrique
noire les états unis essuyé un demi
échec au référendum sur l'europe près de
40% d'abstentions
c'est d'ailleurs en russie à pitchouns
dakhil fait son dernier voyage officiel
à l'étranger
nous sommes le 13 mars 74 nombreux alors
sont les journalistes qui constate la
transformation physique du président
dont les propos au cours de sa dernière
conférence de presse sont déjà
l'annoncent d'une fin prochaine
personne pourtant ne peut deviner quel
drame personnel vie le président
monsieur bré genève m'a invité à faire
une nouvelle visite officielle en union
soviétique et que bien entendu je n'en
ai pas repousser le principe tout temps
répondant et a bien voulu convenir que
c'était naturel qui n'était pas possible
aujourd'hui d'en fixer le moment à
partir du 23 mars et annulations de
visites et de réception vont se succéder
raison officielle l'état de santé du
président est mauvais nul ne s'y trompe
et surtout parce qu'ils fidèlement
partage son existence politique parmi
les hommes qui l'ont servi à la tête de
l'état à pierre messmer reconduit trois
fois dans ses fonctions de premier
ministre
ça n'a pas été sans étonner beaucoup
alors le président pompidou était fidèle
à ce point aux hommes qui le servait oui
sûrement je crois qu'il était très
attaché à des gens qui lui avait
manifesté une certaine fidélité et qui
surtout étaient des gens solides
ça a été quelque chose de très important
dans son esprit il a même beaucoup la
solidité chez les gens qui étaient en
charge de l'état
d'autre part il était un petit peu
sceptique à l'égard des hommes est
considéré que dans le personnel
politique dans les hommes politiques il
y avait beaucoup de gens qui qui était
surtout attachés à leurs propres
intérêts qui était surtout attaché à
faire carrière
il était très sévère féroce cruel à
l'égard de ces hommes là je crois que ce
qui lui a plu ce qui l'a séduit beaucoup
chez pierre messmer c'est qu'il était le
contraire de ça c'est que c'était un
homme qui ne donnait absolument pas
l'impression d'avoir une carrière
d'avoir même un destin devant lui et
s'est d'ailleurs vérifié
quelques mois plus tard ça s'est vérifié
je pense que très profondément pendant
quelques mois
georges pompidou aurait souhaité que
pierre messmer une plus grande audience
dans le pays et qu'ils puissent avoir
lui aussi un destin national je crois
que pierre messmer dans son esprit
correspondait vraiment à l'idée qu'il se
faisait d'un homme d'état durant
vraiment vous avez
et donc le premier ministre de georges
pompidou quels ont été les rapports du
premier ministre il présent république à
ce moment-là rapports humains
or les rapports du crâne lisse et du
président d'avic de tout premier
ministre avec tout premier président de
la république président de république
sont des rapports fréquents puisque le
premier ministre voyez georges pompidou
au moins trois fois par semaine le lundi
et le vendredi matin en tête à tête il
mercredi à l'occasion du conseil des
ministres
voir un homme au moins trois fois par
semaine et quelquefois plus c'est
évidemment l'occasion de le commettre
l'occasion de nouer avec lui des
rapports qui ne sont pas seulement des
rapports de fonction mais aussi des
rapports d'amitié
ces rapports d'amitié t2 et se situer
sur quel plan
d'abord elles des rapports de confiance
crise est indispensable
le président de la république et
confiance dans son premier ministre et
je crois que georges pompidou me faisait
confiance
en tout cas il l'a montré comment
georges pompidou appréhender t-il sur le
plan humain et les grands problèmes
c'est un homme d'une grande clarté
d'esprit intelligence tout à fait
exceptionnel on l'a dit souvent et avec
raison et je crois que son intelligence
lui permettait d'aller tout de suite à
l'essentiel je dirais que c'est la
caractéristique principale de son
intelligence il y avait des
intelligences discursive c'est à dire
qu'il s'efforce de saisir tous les
aspects d'un problème et ensuite de
rassembler tous ses aspects afin d'en
chercher la composante principale la
capacité intellectuelle georges pompidou
lui permettait d'aller tout de suite
d'une sorte de vue extrêmement rapide
vers l'essentiel d'un sujet je crois que
c'est la caractéristique de son
intelligence puis ensuite c'est un homme
qui avait une grande sensibilité
politique
il était très sensible
au mouvement de l'opinion il sentait ou
en tout cas croyez sentir l'évolution de
cette opinion et je crois que sa maladie
il avait même rendu encore plus sensible
dans les derniers mois
un an après à quelques jours après la
disparition du président pompidou est ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment que
l'image qu'il a laissé parmi les
français s'est trouvé un peu amoindrie
où je crois pas qu'il est amoindrie je
crois pas qu'elle est altérée non plus
je pense que un an après la mort de
georges pompidou
beaucoup de français pensent à autre
chose mais leur opinion sur georges
pompidou ne s'est pas détériorée en
quelque sorte de ce point de vue il ya
un phénomène qui est un phénomène
général en france au moins c'est ce
qu'on appelle le purgatoire après sa
mort un homme politique un écrivain un
artiste entre souvent dans une période
de semis oublie ce n'est pas le cas pour
georges pompidou mais certains que après
avoir beaucoup parler de lui lorsqu'il
était président de la république eh bien
on en parle très peu maintenant je crois
que c'est un phénomène général et qui
toucheraient qui touche d'autres hommes
que lui vous avez été très proche de lui
donc durant 20 mois
quel est le souvenir très très précis
vous en conserver est ce que une
rencontre plus particulièrement où des
propos qui vous aurez de mieux vous ont
frappé ce le souvenir qui est le plus le
plus fort en moi de georges pompidou
c'est ce comportement qui a été le sien
pendant les dernières années de sa vie
c'est à dire le comportement d'un homme
qui se savait malade qui se sentaient
malades et qui ont dépit de sa maladie
en dépit de ces souffrances même voulait
continuer à assumer sa fonction
l'assumait d'ailleurs complètement
entièrement et par conséquent donnait à
ceux qui le voyaient vivre c'était mon
cas un exemple un très bel exemple de
courage et en particulier de courage
civique le 27 mars et le dernier conseil
des ministres
nul ne pressent l'importance de
l'événement il évoque la prochaine
session parlementaire les relations
europe etats unis et donne des conseils
à ses ministres qu'ils doivent prévoir
la crise qui pointe déjà à l'horizon
politique
nous nous trouvons devant des années est
en tout cas une année qui sera bien les
gars difficile cela peut nous étonner
par ce que nous avons vécu des années à
bien les égards d'une facilité
exceptionnel mêlant fin je comprends
très bien que devant les difficultés il
faille faire un retour sur soi même
devant ces difficultés nous ne devrons
pas vous ne vais pas courber l'échiné
les cétacés attendre que l'orage nous
est abandonné nous ne devons pas non
plus au jour le jour à potasser tant
bien que mal la situation
en tout cas les éléments de telle ou
telle situation il faut que le
gouvernement avec une politique
pitau qui est une volonté il faut qu'il
est là présente à l'esprit quand le
gouvernent qu'en prévoyant et en asie ce
qui donne le vertige comme ça que je
vois quelqu'un non écoute cet instant
prix l'action de georges pompidou ne
sera pas seulement politique
passionné d'art et de culture il
favorise les arts les fait rentrer à
l'elysée où il s'entoure d'oeuvres
contemporaines qu'il sait apprécier et
mettre en valeur dans des appartements
qu'ils rénovent de fond en comble le
calme
le conservatisme apparent du président
cache un passionné des arts et des
lettres modernes et en particulier de la
peinture à laquelle il voue une
véritable passion
oui c'était sa grande passion
personnellement il l'est mais vous savez
beaucoup la peinture moderne d'ailleurs
déjà à l'hôtel matignon son bureau dans
son bureau les l'étoile ligne
c'est historique avait été remplacé par
des toiles de soulager les trois leviers
tels même assez agressive quand on
entrait dans son bureau et c'était sa
grande passion je crois que dès qu'il
s'est installé à l'elysée il a un peu
souffert de ne pas pouvoir se promener à
pied dans paris pour aller dans les
galeries de la rive gauche voir ce qui
se faisait en matière d'armes dernier de
recherche d'art plastique et le plateau
beaubourg correspond à ses voeux alors
le plateau beaubourg corée ce point
indiscutablement à quelque chose qui
était très très très précieux à ses yeux
précieux également pour georges pompidou
les contacts humains avec les français
avec sa famille un contact qu'il perdra
parfois sous le poids écrasant de sa
charge et que toujours il cherchera à
renouer et la solitude de sa fonction
l'inquiétant sera bien souvent ses
preuves un des aspects les plus
difficiles à supporter dans la vie de
chef d'état et de responsables
c'est cette espèce de distance qui
s'installe entre vous et les autres et
qui sauf en famille tout de même grâce
au ciel existe toujours s'installe petit
à petit ses marques
on le sent on n'est pas pour les autres
n'importe qui est-ce qu'elle en souffre
moi j'en souffre est-ce que vous avez
essayé monsieur le président de réduire
cette distance et j'essaie le plus
possible constamment j'essaie de me
tenir au contact et même de me mettre au
niveau si vous voulez de chacun je le
fait d'ailleurs part parce que je
déteste tout ce qui va pas ça par an à
la solitude je le fais aussi au fond
parce qu'il me semble que si on veut
bien comprendre la vie et donc les gens
et donc la vie d'un pays
eh bien il faut essayer de se mettre un
peu à leur place et que si la distance
s'installe trop eh bien on ne se met
plus la place de personne
c'est dans une petite commune du cantal
au coeur de la haute auvergne que né le
3 juillet 1911
georges pompidou s'il quitte très vite
son village natal de montboudif afin de
se rendre à albi où ses parents sont
instituteur il y revient souvent passer
ses vacances scolaires quelques bouts du
montois les anciens gardent jalousement
des souvenirs qu'ils peuvent avoir de
leurs rapports avec l'enfant le plus
illustre de leur village et rares sont
ceux qui ouvrent leurs portes et accepte
d'en parler en 1971 les boues du mantois
accueillent leur président là il n'est
plus question de politique mais tout
simplement de problèmes locaux et puis
si georges pompidou revient souvent à
montboudif c'est également pour se
recueillir sur la tombe de ses pains
cette région que nous allons devoir est
une région dure est-ce que le président
pompidou était à l'image de sa région
et est-ce que politiquement il était
marqué par sa région c'est à dire
'est-ce qu'il dirigeait les affaires
politiques comme un homme justement
originaire de sète auvergne je crois que
ça a été le très grands problèmes qu'il
a eus quand il est arrivé à l'elysée
ils semblaient très bien monde qu'il ne
serait pas de gourou qui ne pourraient
pas imiter le général de gaulle et qui
ne voulaient pas disait qu'il singe et
de ce qui s'était fait avant lui
je crois qu'il était très soucieux de
trouver un certain équilibre autres ce
qu'il appelait la france de louis xiv et
la france de louis philippe il disait je
ne veux pas tomber de la grandeur dans
le pot-au-feu
il était si vous voulez à la fois
soucieux de préserver cette image
tranquille de la france cette image je
dirai encore une fois un peu provincial
de la france mais en même temps il était
très désireux de maintenir une certaine
idée de l'état et ça a été une recherche
constante pendant les années où il était
à l'elysée
de faire savoir aux français au monde
entier que la france continuait de
s'exprimer continuer de parler sur un
même registre pour beaucoup de français
je le disais il y a eu un il y avait
beaucoup d'affection pour le président
pourquoi cette affection je crois
essentiellement parce que c'était un
homme de la terre un homme qui croyait
aux vertus paysanne des français les
français sont des terriens
il n'y a pas de citadins il n'y a pas de
parisiens et parisiens sont tous des
gens de la campagne georges pompidou
considéré que la véritable france
c'était la france de la campagne de la
montagne aussi il se voulait lui même
montagnards il disait je suis comme
légende de ma région j'avance prudemment
je fais toujours attention lorsque je
n'ai un pas devant l'autre se flagellent
vous êtes le boulanger de montboudif
vous avez connu georges pompidou à quel
moment vous l'avez le mieux connue bien
et qu'elle était bien il a commencé à
venir écrit alcoolisme et je n'ai connu
depuis qu'il est à mes yeux qu'il est
parti de l'école des filles
il revenait souvent pour les vacances à
hawaï et une est presque un par un
monsieur mon but était quelqu'un de très
simple et qui aimait bien les gens du
pays et quand gainey à la mairie voyez
ces débats l'un d'eux les problèmes de
la commune mais aussi en ami parce que
c'est quelqu'un que demain vous dire on
n'est pas prêt à remplacer et
j'attendrai là aussi ne pas oublier
qu'il était enfant montpellier a
certainement pas car n'oubliera pas de
sitôt aussitôt que ses charges
présidentielle le lui permette georges
pompidou quitte l'elysée pour se reposer
dans sa propriété de prat joua à cajarc
dans le lot
là il fait de longues promenades à
cheval où il part pêcher la truite et
l'écrevisse il participe un peu à la vie
municipale de cages à il a même été élu
maire l'espace d'un concert à woods 71
lors du renouvellement ni pensée ne suis
pas quelqu'un jarre nous avions des
quelques conseillers décédé et nous
avons demandé à monsieur condé nous de
faire partie de notre liste n'ayant
accepté à condition d'être le 13e sur la
liste
il a donc été élu avec une forte
majorité puisqu'il a vu 1 0 90% des bois
et nous avons demandé d'être mais nous
avons même élu maire de cage a mis
aussitôt il a refusé la le post le maire
est justement à l'occasion de
l'anniversaire de sa mort le 2 avril les
ses anciens collègues du conseil
municipal ont demandé qu'une messe
anniversaire sera célébrée ici à casa
cela se révèle le soir juste avant
l'inauguration d'une avenue qui va
porter le nom de georges pompidou c'est
l'avenue qui donne précisément sur la
propriété qu'il avait acheté après jour
lorsqu'il a été nommé président de la
république
il me dit je serai fidèle à la messe
dominicale du dimanche
et en effet il a tenu parole et il m'a
dit en particulier
je ne veux pas qu'ils cérémonie spéciale
je me mettre au milieu de vos
paroissiens mais
je pense que vous me considérez comme un
de vos paroissiens et en effet lorsqu'il
venait devenait très simplement mais ce
mettez au milieu des parutions n'y avait
même pas de place réservée dans l'église
et passez nous voir et venir nous
inviter tous deux ou trois fois par an
comme ça à prendre le café avec lui il
était très très gentille et puis on
l'approché comme on voulait tout à fait
tout à fait simple ça fait 14 ans qu'il
est là le gars de ce chien ce chien est
à lui l'associât envoyé là et quand il
venait en vacances qui venait vous voir
vous avez l'impression que c'était le
président de la république enfin écoutés
ont compris qu'ils étaient toujours
habillés pas là il se promenait à
toujours habillé pareil c'était et quand
ils nous invitent est tout aussi bien
les servir le café
il était très très très simple très
simple on le regrette énormément et je
vous assure
normal il a pleuré moi aussi savez ces
jours ci à face à lui et le bruit devenu
le journal interne allait devenir ici
[Musique]